alors vive la rentrée une nouvelle école
vous êtes nerveux j'ai l'impression
d'être désespérée est épuisé il ya plus
de 20 millions d'américains qui sont
déprimés d'où est-ce que tu sors ces
informations du pet pour un médicament
elle a trop regardé il y un type
adorable dans mon cours de yoga c'est
que cinq mois que je faisais pas mal
filles c'est mon anniversaire alors vous
savez l'histoire
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien vous offrir vos verres
c'est vrai le patron insiste pour que je
vérifie ton âge j'ai l'âge qu'il faut
pour consommer d'alcool gelé aussi mais
qu'est-ce que je recours je vais
toujours trop loin quand je fête mon
anniversaire
tu as peu mon jour de l'an perso je
finis toujours par bloom et après je
rembobine pour reprendre ma vie normale
tulle à laver oui mais uniquement parce
que j'ai lancé une machine et que je
suis debout depuis 5h30
on ne traîne pas les filles mais qu'est
ce que vous faites ici une mamie devez
vous emmener à l'école tu as l'air
bizarre non merci du fond du coeur adam
key
les apprécie un vaste et moi c'était
vite ils sont sans le sou alors autant
qu'ils occupent la maison d'invités
tu rigoles il se pourrait bien qu au
bout du compte ce soit une belle tu
j'aimerais que les choses soient claires
on va tous faire en sorte que ça
fonctionne je vais choquer ce sachet et
le vidéo twilight ton ex devait vraiment
être à côté de la plaque pour laisser
filer une fille comme toi dégage du
courant dit motivé aussi si tu fais ici
j'en sais rien j'ai plus toute ma tête
c'est l'un d'entre eux
[Musique]
tu lui as tu pour te pièce tu viendras
me voir sur scène j'ai quand même déjà
vendredi prochain
notre famille me manque s'ils ont
réessayé
tu vois tu fais un choix quand tu as 25
ans et puis tu te demandes si c'est
comme ça que tu envisages le rester
je trouve que tu gères vraiment bien
[Musique]
le petit déjeuner est servi
tout va bien se passer bonsoir année
ok